hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to our special homeroom
edition
on college is college right for me or i
guess is college right for you we have a
very exciting group of panelists young
people who are maybe a few years ahead
of many of y'all who are expert in
several domains but especially expert in
thinking about college when it's right
what other options there are and how to
make the most of it but before we jump
into that i will give my standard
reminders first of all we are a
not-for-profit and if you're in a
position to do so please think about
going to khan academy.org slash donate
it's because of your donations if you're
in a position to do so that make khan
academy possible to reach hundreds of
millions of folks around the world i
also want to give a special shout out to
several organizations
that have gone above and beyond in
supporting khan academy especially since
the seemingly never ending pandemic
started over over a year and a half ago
special thanks to bank of america at t
google.org novartis
fastly and general motors and the many
other supporters across the board who
have uh contributed to khan academy to
allow
us to do the work that we do
so and final announcement there is a
podcast version of this live stream
wherever you get your podcast homeroom
with sal the podcast so i encourage you
to check that out as well
so with that out of the way i am super
excited to introduce our panelists
and i will actually ask them to juice
themselves but we have delicia who is a
cyber security expert and also a recent
college grad we have madison who is a
designer artist
associated with cnn plus and also a
recent college grad and we have ernest
who is a software engineer at google and
founder and president of code house and
also a recent college grad but
delisha let me start with you
tell us a little bit about who you are
and your journey
into becoming a cyber security expert
yes style thank you i'm so glad to be
here hi everyone out there i am delicia
hutto an undergraduate cyber security
student advisor at south stated in my
career i have the pleasure of advising
as well as supporting uh students and
future defenders uh in the cyber
security space and rim
and in that work we're making sure that
they are trained so that they can not
only defend
our world in the cyber security world
but also defend you in the different
things that you love to do
when i'm not advising i am the chair of
our sans hbcu team where our goal is to
support juniors and seniors at
historically black colleges and
universities
receive free cyber security training and
certifications as well
and honestly what led me to this path of
cyber security was honestly by chance um
i actually majored in psychology got my
bachelor's in psychology and it's one of
those majors where
it allows you to go anywhere and end up
anywhere and i'm one of those people
that pretty much i would say cyber
security found me and i wouldn't have
any other way is as it allows me to
watch other students and other
individuals achieve greatness while also
defending the world from cyber attacks
and bad actors
as well as supporting others and
hopefully
inspiring more of you out there to help
us defend
and become cyber security experts as
well
i love that deletion i'm going to ask
you many more questions about it
especially because
at least what you're advising these
undergraduate students to do it's like
they could get to live in a tom clancy
level they get to like defend the
country and you know in the cyber world
which is obviously only becoming a
bigger and bigger thing uh but let's go
to you ernest tell me a little bit about
your journey uh and and and how you
ended up both as a software engineer but
also
uh what you're doing at codehouse
sure so thanks for the introduction glad
to be here hello everyone my name is
ernest holmes i grew up in new jersey
and i made it all the way down to
atlanta to attend college at moore house
college
morehouse college is an historically
black institution serving all black men
and while at moore house i was very
aware about the many opportunities that
exist in the tech industry and when i
was just a freshman i actually wound up
getting an internship at google to be a
software engineer so i spent every
summer actually while i was at morehouse
interning at google out in california so
they flew me out got to work on amazing
projects from advertisement to mobile
development to
um
artificial intelligence machine learning
on these robotic flowers
and that eventually allowed me to become
a full-time software engineer at google
working on the fuchsia team so that's my
day job uh that's what i do and i'm very
passionate about being the tech industry
but i also realized that there was a
need for more people color
to be exposed to especially at an
earlier age to the different
opportunities as this exists in the tech
industry whether it's engineering or
design product management and
that allowed me to get together not only
with my sister but one of my best
friends thomas thompson and the other
person on this call
madison tivier and a bunch of other
great individuals to make code house
which is all about exposing students
college to tech industry so we expose
midon high school students to different
careers in the tech industry but then
now we also support early college uh
students with scholarships that's right
scholarships so we can actually pay for
your schooling if you're interested in
going to tech industry and attending an
hvcu um so that's a little about me and
i guess the last that i wear right now
i'm also actually a professor at
morehouse college uh teaching freshman
computer science so wearing a few
different hats right now
i i want to ask you more questions about
that we actually already have questions
coming in through youtube and i
encourage everyone watching to start
putting your questions for any of these
very impressive young people that you
see in front of you uh but i have one
question before i move on to madison
what does the fuchsia team work on is
you know fuchsia is just a color
what what is the fuchsia dude
i'm glad you asked
yeah fuchsia is actually an offering
system that we're building from scratch
completely open sourced
and it's actually one of the first large
developments of offering systems that's
non-linux based so if you little
background every single thing that works
right now computers phones they're all
derived and based in this thing called
linux we decided to make a offering
system that is not based on linux so
it's rethinking how computers work and
how eventually different devices can
interact with one another super cool
project super cool team um and hopefully
you'll see a lot more future
and i'm still wondering how it's
connected to the color but maybe we'll
get into that
here's another point
but but madison tell us a little bit
about your journey um on how you got to
where you are as a designer and an
artist
yeah well hey everyone good afternoon
good evening good morning wherever you
are
my name is madison mativier i am a proud
and loud 2019 graduate of howard
university earning a bachelor's in fine
arts wooden design
and a double minor in art history in
german
so that love for art actually brought me
to my current position i am a graphic
artist slash production designer at cnn
plus for those who may not be familiar
with cnn plus it's totally okay
it actually launches next year it's cnn
streaming platform
so kind of like an hbo max a netflix but
cnn so what that compiles is a couple
things i can't talk about but
very generally it's a bunch of unique tv
and tv programming that you can access
on a streaming platform
on my well that's my day job
after you know after 6 pm i kind of
switch hats and i'm not only the
creative director at code house
corporation as earnest so eloquently
explained um but i'm also owner of my
own creative agency augie creative where
we work with brands such as ruby
ruby rose
it's been a crazy
wild ride with the amounts of clients
and types from small businesses to
larger ones such as quality control
music universal music group um as well
as you know community centers within the
dallas area
um and yeah my love of art really
brought me here to be quite honest with
you
that's incredible you know i i like i'd
like to think that i was i was i i was
doing pretty well for myself in my early
20s but y'all are making me feel
somewhat insecure about what i was doing
with myself given all that y'all have
already accomplished but
the the topic of today is
college is it is it right for me or is
it right for the folks listening and you
can imagine there's a lot of young
people some of them are saying i want to
go to college some folks are saying i'm
not sure there might be other paths and
then even amongst the people who are
thinking about college they're saying
can i afford it how do i figure out how
to navigate it what types of colleges
should i go through so i'd like to go
one by one through all again and say how
were you thinking about it when you were
16 or 17 years old did you have some of
these doubts how did you navigate these
doubts was it random chance were there
certain things you did that helped you
make
better decisions and actually i'll go in
the same word delish i'll start with you
yeah for me um i was a first-gen so
first in my family to actually attend
college and graduate um so for me it was
a lot of exploration a lot of thinking
um i initially actually wanted to go
into
audio engineering so
leading into music production because i
love music and i'm a very creative
person and
i soon discovered something that you're
going to speak about and you spoke a
little bit too of the financial piece
i
sadly discovered that financially the
school wasn't a fit for me and i was
going to be able to go into audio
engineering so that's when i made that
pivot to my plan b psychology and
haven't looked back since
but
for me i'll say
it's a unique path especially if you are
a future first generation student out
there in the world and you're in the
first in your family there's a lot of
resources out there there's a lot of
people that you can lean on and what i
will say to you is
life is not a straight path so don't be
worried if you do not end up in a career
in your major that's pretty normal right
now in the world that we live in um but
that doesn't mean that you're a failure
what it means is you you are brave
enough to take a chance and that you
still have light years ahead of you to
discover what your passion is and to do
something that makes you happy
and to make sure i understand you were
originally thinking about audio
engineering and you decided to move out
of that because
it was at a different school and that
was too expensive or you were thinking
that the career might be harder to
attain than how how did you make that
transition
initially come in the state of georgia
it was only one college that actually
offered anything near to audio
engineering and that college was
savannah college of art and design um
it's a private college so with that it
was extremely expensive and again as i
said before i'm first-gen first in my
family we're not the richest in the
world um so when i received that
financial aid package i realized wow
even with a scholarship i i can't afford
30 000 a year or however much it was so
i had to make that conscious decision to
say you know what i do like psychology
so let me pivot my plan b is going to be
i'm going to pivot to psychology i'm
going to see where it takes me and if
it's meant to be i'll always find my way
back to music whether it's through audio
engineering or just finding ways to
express myself in other ways whether
through spoken word which i do poetry um
or just enjoying listening to music and
analyzing it so you can still find those
joys without initially going into that
major or ending up in that career so
that's kind of how i was able to pivot
and change my mindset about it and quite
frankly didn't really have a choice
because of the financial situation but i
feel like at the end of the day looking
back on it it was the right choice to
make and not go into that
as much of that i'm doing that
and
as always because i'm still young if i
really wanted to go back into audio
engineering i'm sure i could
no and thanks for sharing that story
because i think students don't hear
those stories enough because so many
times in a forum like this people like
oh just
you know do whatever you want and all
that and there's your students saying
but how am i gonna pay for that or you
know and you know i remember being in a
similar situation uh
my family you know we we grew up not a
lot of resources and i remember my
sister applying to a school i'm like how
are we going to pay for and i think at
the time you know this was in the 90s it
was 25 000 years like we that's more
than my mom makes that's twice what my
mom makes in a year how we're going to
do that and then my sister explained to
me about the whole financial aid system
and all of that so to your your story
you know it sounds like
look at look it sounds like you did the
right things you you said what am i
interested in but you explored the
options you said okay now what are they
offering
they might be offering a little bit of
scholarship a little bit of financial
aid but it still was not practical but
there's other really good options and
obviously now you are helping other
people defend our country against cyber
threats and whatever and whatever else
ernest how how did you think about this
when you were 16 or 17 did you always
know you were going to be a software
engineer did you always know you're
going to go to college did you always
think it was going to be morehouse how
do you navigate that